it's time for the first reaction video
of 2019 I'm excited just came back from
Costa Rica maybe you could notice the
tan Nurse Jackie episode 1 season 1 what
do you call a nurse with a bad back
unemployed no those Tomatoes
[Music]
we were thirty Marines I like cherry
tomatoes those are not cherry tomatoes
she's doing lines can you show me two
fingers Theatre two fingers hey duck you
should get an iPhone do you think so
all right this doctor is absolutely
awful this doesn't happen in hospitals
if it does people should be losing their
medical licenses the patient's clearly
mentally unstable or has some sort of
altered mental status because he's in
and out of the conversation
he can't hold up two fingers and those
doctors like checking his Blackberry and
talking about a vacation to st. Barts
come on bro and first of all who has a
blackberry I used to he's got a bleed
I'm telling you right now he's totally
lucid 100% not who's there see what'd I
tell you it's not how we determine
someone's neurological status we do
something known as the Glasgow Coma
Scale which gives you a score from 0 to
15 depending on how Lert you are besides
that we do a complete neurological
examination we don't just look at
someone make a knock-knock joke and just
assume they're good acute subdural
haematoma the brain puffs up so fast it
rips the blood vessels and you bleed to
death inside your skull the skull is a
closed environment and when you bleed
into the skull that builds up extreme
pressure now that pressure exhibits what
we call Mass Effect on to the brain and
puts even more pressure and causes your
brain cells to die horrible that this
patient had to lose his life like this
for what because the doctor had an ego
and wanted to look cool in front of the
nurse she should not have died I do
Peter Michael
Donegan
why she forging his shoes but it will
not be a waste if she forged his organ
donor certificate on the back of his
license that's crazy I have no words for
that we work 911 not a scratch on us
Petey's job is to ride a bike and he
gets killed
riding a bike is incredibly dangerous
when I worked at a level 1 trauma center
we would see bike accidents happen all
the time and unfortunately many of these
people don't wear helmets and
essentially what happens is they come in
horrible brain bleed and it's often too
late for us to even intervene in the
hospital and they lose their lives I
tell you to order a scan you order a god
damn scan because if you don't do it
I'll just go to the next doctor and the
next doctor after that in the meantime
that kid died and it is all on you is
this happening not happening like you
didn't tell oh [ __ ]
oh crap all right I'm so sorry
Oh God I know when I get nervous I act
out with inappropriate sexual touches
it's like a it's like Tourette's it's
it's gone it's over okay it happened and
now it's over so there's that I don't
like chatty okay I don't do chatty I
like quiet quiet and mean those are my
people I've worked with nurses that were
mean like this and I will say that
secretly inside despite this mean
exterior they have the biggest and
sweetest hearts they care about people
and the only reason they're so mean is
because they want to protect their
patients they don't put up with nonsense
so I defend you mean nurses that's all
I've got some Jon getting off cutting up
hookers in the back of a limo I'm turn
the alphabet now again the lookout for
Vincent van Gogh and there's a [ __ ]
suit got the blade with me so you never
want to take an organ like that that is
very sensitive and put it directly on
ice you want to wrap it in a wet cloth
and then put that on ice because the ice
can actually damage the tissue almost
like creating frostbite you away from
here Zoe
typical day well what do you doctors
have against healing people for
chrissake
yeah yeah you see that that right there
Healing helping fixing fantastic that's
why you're a nurse
I'm not digging the stereotype right now
doctors help people when we go get
lunches or dinners together we talk
about what we could have done better we
try and learn from our cases so I'm
taking this to heart right now and bad
nerves Jackie show writer four minutes
till brain damage to Toshi poses up I
got it you're buying lunch by doing the
Heimlich maneuver like that what you're
doing is you're increasing the
intra-abdominal pressure which then
forces the air out therefore helping you
push out whatever it is that you're
choking on or this poor lady in this
case is choking on sixteen year-old male
shuttle roll the candle out of his ass
third-degree burns and a scrotum and
perirectal air oh he put a firework in
his butt let me close the door
never in my life have I examined the
patient let alone examine the patient in
in stirrups with the door open like that
come on now come on now I cannot even
begin to imagine what it must feel like
to be you right now
and I'm not gonna cushion it and tell
you I'm so sorry for your loss I know it
is much bigger than that but I am deeply
deeply sorry but if it's any comfort
he's gonna be a hero now
his body is gonna save lives it's
actually an incredibly good speech
concise easy to understand
still apologetic without going too far
except obviously the fact that she lied
and forged his organ donor signature
fine can I have his heart whoa I'm sorry
took a turn oh how about a kidney I know
this like this organ market where rich
people buy pay a lot of money for body
parts I know it doesn't work that way
20,000 bucks for a kidney don't you
think he holds me that for getting
himself killed and I got them bike a
family member or a girlfriend of someone
who just died give me one of his organs
so I can sell it on the black market
what he made me pancakes this one and
you want to sell us kidney
you know what's funny I've never seen
these pills before because eh I don't
take them and B when I order them for my
patients I don't see them they pick them
up either at the pharmacy or even at
bedside the nurse brings them to the
patients so I've never seen these pills
what doctors have is we have some great
apps like Epocrates that we can open get
information about the the medications
we're giving you can check the dosing
the formulary adverse reactions drug
interactions but then you go click here
for pill pictures and you could see but
none of these look like the ones she was
using
what about like oxycontin he'll pick
chairs
none of these are red oh oh these kind
of look like what she was using right
that woman you cut took 287 stitches and
10 pints of blood she liked to cut
herself that was her idea
yes American women are very adventurous
she probably did it for attention what
do you do for attention I'll be right
back I'm gonna save that boy that
messenger kid I knew there was a bleed I
felt it this is where we need to use
this as a learning opportunity to create
a system in their Hospital like my
Hospital has where anyone whether you're
nurse
part of the janitorial staff doctor
resident can report an error like this
that needs to be investigated by the
staff so it doesn't happen again and
even if let's say they had a good
outcome and she still felt like she
wasn't being heard she needs to come on
to that system and report what we call a
near miss and a near miss is when a
mistake almost happens even though you
catch it but you you still use it as a
learning opportunity to make sure that a
near miss doesn't even happen again do
you think there's a finite amount of
pain
in the world like if I take the thorn
out of someone's hand to that pain and
have to go somewhere else
yes that's why there's drugs no disagree
I think you're a saint just so you know
I like our bunny scrubs I'm jealous I
want a pair like that I almost killed
you
that's why we don't take drugs on the
job it's pretty funny but it looks like
those bags are just saline so I don't
know how she almost killed them but it
doesn't look like it that's what we call
a near-miss by the way walking overnight
that's a night okay brought you
something for your back
dr. pepper
Moonpie
it's thinking more along the lines of
vicodin there's actually been a lot of
scandals with doctors and pharmacists
either over prescribing narcotics or
maybe even getting caught stealing
narcotics now they're locked up in these
machines in my hospital they're called
Pyxis machines where you need to
actively get fingerprint or scan your
badge in order to get any kind of number
of medications out also there's been a
lot of doctors where I come from in
Brooklyn that have been arrested and
charged with distributing these
narcotics because they were just writing
scripts for patients non-stop or 100
pills hundred pills unlimited refills
those who haven't yet been caught be
wary because we are coming for you be
careful yeah whoa welcome to New York
[Music]
how did he not catch that no joke I am a
fan of Nurse Jackie it's not a doctor
show there's enough medical stuff for me
to comment on for sure if you want a
funny video check out my bloopers click
it you know you wanna stay happy and
healthy